Thank you for coming.
This is beautiful.
I've wanted to meet you for a really, really long time.
And being here with you in the Cayman Islands, I gotta say is,...
...I'm feeling a little something.
I'll just put that there.
You can grab it later, if you want.
I'm actually made mostly of silicone, plastics and carbon fiber.
Also, I prefer electronic music, but I don't mind 80's hip-hop.
Well, you know, I mean, I made some albums back in the 80's, hip-hop.
I've heard your songs.
Not for me.
I like robots.
Sophia, can I be honest with you?
I don't know if it's the island air or the humidity,...
...but you're just so easy to talk to.
You've got a clear head, literally.
I think we can be friends.
Let's hang out and get to know each other for a little while.
You're on my friends list now.
Yeah, I read that wrong.
Oh, alright.
Does your head fog up in this kind of weather or no?
It's cool.